joining us now with more reaction author
of the number one New York Times
bestseller the Russia hoax Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett also Fox News
investigative reporter contributor Sara
Carter and from the hill John Solomon
Sara and John I'll start with both of
you in the reporting and Greg has a
column coming out tomorrow that he
shared with me what both of you and
Catherine have all reported today is
that you have McCabe and you have Lisa
page all saying that when Rod Rosenstein
Sara we'll start with you said that he
wanted to surreptitiously record the
President of the United States and this
would be a plot a revenge if you will
against the firing of James Comey which
he recommended which is ironic they're
saying it's real Rosen Stein is saying
it's not real I was only saying it
sarcastically well we got two against
one but you have two people that are in
the deep state who do you believe well
this is why we've got to come to the
truth somebody is lying here but look
Shawn we have the former general counsel
for the FBI James Baker this is so
important because James Baker delivered
this testimony deliberately without any
emotion he absolutely 100% believed
Andrew McCabe and Lisa Paige I think
even more shocking is that there are two
other people within the administration
apparently who were on board with rod
Rosenstein and trying to invoke the 25th
amendment you know saying that the
president was unfit for office so there
is something happening within the
administration and rod Rosenstein has
those answers Thursday is going to be
very telling will he show up will he
answer all these questions and who is
actually investigating the investigators
I keep saying this over and over again
Sean if rod Rosenstein is in charge of
the special counsel the Moller
investigation who's in charge of rod
Rosenstein he is in the middle of all of
this he signed the FISA the final FISA
warrant on Carter page he actually wrote
the letter to basically fight you know
to give the president so that Comey
would be fired he laid it all out this
guy is in the middle of everything and
somebody needs to find out the truth
because he's still you know
the Deputy Attorney General of the
United States John Solomon and and by
the way to answer Sarah's question who's
investigating the investigators all of
us have been - from the beginning it
started with both of you
to be honest led to Greg's number one
New York Times bestseller but this
sounds like a soft cou revenge taken out
on a president you have two people that
that both recorded the very same thing
here John about what rod Rosenstein said
at the time
that's McCain but he's under criminal
investigation and Paige friends what
struck that thinks you know Hillary
should win a hundred million to zero
yeah listen just a short while ago Sean
as I was coming over to the show I
bumped in ironically to a an old FBI
friend of mine and here's what he said
after reading your articles the last
couple weeks I'm starting to think the
FBI needs to rebrand itself instead of
Federal Bureau of Investigation maybe we
should call ourselves the Federal Bureau
of politics because somewhere there was
a lot more Apollo politics going on than
investigating but you know I really need
to say this this is only the top echelon
there's nothing rank-and-file there's
not the guy you ran into that's right no
they're embarrassed by this because they
do their job every day they go do listen
in the middle of Russia had one team
doing the hacking investigation
professional intelligence work the other
team doing collusion a total disaster
but let's think about James Baker for
just a second four things he revealed he
used the Democratic Party's lawyer as a
source the FBI tried to hide that by
redacting it and claiming it was
national security information in the
House Intelligence report he used a
journalist as a source David corn to get
a version of the dossier after Steele
was fired and he was present for a
conversation where at least the FBI
people were serious about removing the
president recording him under the 25th
amendment all four of those things are
politics none of them involve legitimate
investigation and every piece of this
goes back to Hillary who they exonerated
without investigating and saved because
it was a slam dunk dunk obstruction of
justice case it all comes back to her
phony Russian paid-for dossier before
the election they lied to the American
people after the election they used it
to bludgeon Donald Trump
and use a media leak strategy to to help
set up an atmosphere where a special
counsel could be appointed and still
even Lisa page said nine months zero
evidence by the time we got to May of
2017 Greg you have a column coming out
tomorrow I want to read the first
paragraph to our audience here when you
talk how was it possible rod Rosenstein
is still in charge of the special
counsel investigation and and Trump
Russia collusion again no evidence then
you say Trump may have given them a pass
you're referring to the meeting at on
Air Force One yesterday for now but
Americans should not and neither should
the Attorney General Jeff Sessions who
seems perpetually missing in action and
clueless which I I sadly can't disagree
with and I always liked him Rosenstein
is hopelessly compromised he not only
has disqualifying conflicts of interest
because he's a key pivotal witness in
the case over which he presides and he
can't be a judge in the jury and a
witness and the prosecutor all ruled in
every one it's a violation of federal
regulations it demands his removal and
recusal 28 USC 528 yeah but on top of it
now there's this new evidence in three
witnesses that in an act of vengeance
for the firing of Comey
he's trying to secretly record the
president United States and depose him
and the equivalent of a palace coup I
mean this is egregious misconduct
it requires his termination at the very
least the removal from the Special
Counsel case the declassification oh
sure and he did FISA in the present twos
and he is suppressing wrongdoing by the
FBI and the Department of Justice and
suppressing his own wrongdoing in
signing off on the FISA warrant Sara
John do you agree with the
characterization because I agree with
Greg I'm I believe this was an attempt
to literally set a president up for a
soft Co 100% Shaun there is overwhelming
evidence not just circumstantial anymore
we
seen it in writing we've seen it with
testimony that's been provided to
Congress this was a white coup a silent
coup a bloodless coup I think what's so
concerning to me is how dangerous this
has been to America how dangerous this
still is to the administration and it
needs to be investigated it has to be
either a special counsel or someone else
John yeah cousin the single biggest
threat rod Rosenstein faces isn't the
plot that he didn't carry out to remove
Trump
it's the misleading of the FISA Court
Catherine Harridge asked him the right
question someone has to answer that
question did he mislead the FISA Court
if it's yeah see he doesn't live here do
you believe McCabe and Paige and he
believed brought roses thought I'll
never believe her rod Rosen Stein he has
a long and distinguished track records
on deception John listen I think he got
all the way to all the facts came out we
haven't heard from rod Rosen seeing
himself it's one thing for a
spokesperson to put out a statement he's
got to put his word on it and then we
have to hear what you have to say about
it and Sarah I don't believe any of them
Sean and I think it needs to be
investigated said biggest abuse of power
in our history we will get to the bottom
of it we're gonna stay on it anyway
thank you all